and one of the reasons why I'd reach a
student wanted to do this conversation
was I saw that you were one of the first
if not the first to recently talk about
the domestic deployment of the 82nd
airborne right and it just kind of
caught me off guard of wait a second
here's a guy who comes from the Special
Forces in Ranger world so he has an
understanding of how the military works
that most don't have to
he has got early access or first access
to a story that it's pretty big deal for
a whole bunch of reasons we get into and
then three was like the mainstream media
either hadn't picked it up yet didn't
understand the gravity of the situation
or whatever and so it to me just like
really highlighted like this is kind of
the future of a lot of reporting right
is more of the independence being able
to leverage their personal experiences
their personal networks and access to
information to surface as you said
earlier like the truth right and that's
so powerful today so maybe let's start
with just like talk us through kind of
that story and kind of how you came
across it and why you thought it was
important enough to kind of bring it to
light on Twitter and elsewhere yeah sure
you know they absolutely with all the
the recent civil unrest going on in the
United States and we had a protest
movement a peaceful protest movement and
unfortunately some rioters and some
other violent aspects you know trying to
hijack that movement and you know a
heavy police presence getting deployed
the National Guard being deployed and
these are all things that are sort of to
be expected right and for a governor to
deploy the National Guard is perfectly
lawful and evil and normal there's
nothing irregular about that but then
when I had a source reach out to me and
say that the 82nd Airborne Division's
IRF their immediate response force had
been told to pack their bags and get
ready to leave this was back on Saturday
so two Saturdays ago now that they had
been you know as leasts on a self
initiative they've been too alerted and
told to be ready to go they received the
actual alert a few days later on Monday
they were out doing E I be Wayne's an
expert infantry badge so they're on Fort
Bragg on their base doing
normal infantry training and they get
the word that they are being deployed
this is it there they have a CONUS the
mystic deployment and MP cars pulled up
blocked off the roads so that they could
get right to their station right to
their brigade dry out all of their gear
throw it on pallets pack it all do
whatever they had to do and then get
down to Pope Air Force Base and they
were prepped there and in the early
morning hours it would have been Tuesday
early Tuesday they flew on helicopters
huge 60 helicopters Blackhawks and c-17
transport transport aircraft and flew to
Joint Base Andrews in the National
Capital Region so as I was I first
learned about this when the initial
alert happened on Saturday I reported it
then when they actually deployed that
Tuesday early Tuesday morning I reported
on that and it was kind of shocking that
yeah the rest of the press did not pick
up on this story until way later I and I
could speculate on why that is but at
the end of the day you had what is now a
very irregular deployment happening you
have active-duty paratroopers being
deployed ostensibly
I mean for riot control measures on US
soil now the 82nd airborne has been
deployed in this sort of capacity in the
past back in like the 1970s maybe there
was one in the 1980s but it's sending
paratroopers after you know protestors
or rioters in American cities it's not
something that happens every day in
order to do it president Trump probably
would have had to evoke the 1807
insurrection act which is essentially a
loophole the Posse Comitatus that says
in times where there is rebellion in
insurrection where people are having
their constitutional rights violated but
the states cannot or will not protect
those people's rights then the federal
government can deploy active-duty
soldiers to try to mitigate that so in a
lot of ways we walked right up to the
brink last week we walked right up to
that line
up to that precipice you know the United
States military has amazing support from
the American public and like poll after
poll like America loves the military
they love the troops but the day that we
have active duty soldiers in the streets
god forbid killing people because an
altercation erupts between protesters or
rioters and you can do you just imagined
the Wikipedia page on that one in 2030
saying you know general Milley presided
over the 82nd Airborne Division's
deployment to Washington DC during the
2020 riots where they opened fire on
peaceful civil rights demonstrators
something like that and I mean thank God
that didn't happen but we came really
close to it this last week yeah and I
think part of my understanding of this
right is there's kind of multiple stages
of importance so one is just like you
described the deployment of active duty
military a lot of people don't realize
the National Guard is not active duty
military it's very much run by the state
governors and and so it has kind of a
different kind of objective and a
different organizational structure yes
they have a uniform that looks pretty
similar yes they've got guns like all
that kind of stuff but it but it is
different to your point just being
deployed is a big step but to is that
deployment has a connotation that comes
with it of much more kind of serious
clampdown right from the federal
government and I think you and I
probably both see a situation where like
soldiers are Americans first and they
are very much there to kind of protect
and serve and want to do the right
things but they also are trained very
differently than the police right and so
it's kind of your point maybe kind of
elaborate on that a little bit of just
like you have probably some of the best
training in the world coming from that
it's very different than the six you
know six week to six month kind of
police training program like how do you
think about that difference yeah I would
point out also I don't have any critique
of the 82nd airborne
I mean these are good soldiers and the
immediate response force the IRF is you
know it's advertised as America's nine
nine one one call right the president
called him up and immediately deploy
them they did on New Year's Eve as
tensions were mounting with Iran they
deployed to Iraq so I mean these guys
did their job and they are effective and
the IRF is effective and it can't
function in times of emergency when
America needs paratroopers you know on
target these guys can do it the problem
in this case is that the 82nd airport
isn't trained or equipped for riot
control it's not their job they're
paratroopers they're airborne
infantrymen I mean think about the guys
who jumped into Normandy right that's
their bread and butter that's what they
do these guys can maneuver and close
with and destroy the enemy I you know as
maybe some NCOs might say they you know
kill people and break things that's
their job that's the army this is what
they do
so deploying those same soldiers for a
domestic disturbance to do some sort of
riot control uh is very concerning
because the you know you have soldiers
who are wired up they're looking to
fight this is what they do and you know
once one of them gets hit with a brick
you don't know what's gonna you don't
really know how quickly that's gonna
escalate and what are the the force
control measures what are that
escalation measures what are the are OE
going to look like and I can tell you
and I haven't talked about this or
written about this anywhere else but
when they deployed the IRF that it was
specifically it was the median response
battalion one of the immediate response
force so I RB one deployed Joint Base
Andrews they get there then they get
moved to a gymnasium at Fort Belvoir and
they are sitting on cots and you had
82nd airborne paratroopers sitting
around discussing with one another the
legalities of what they're being asked
to do and they're having conversations
about the US Constitution and whether or
not this is right or wrong and I don't
fault them for that at all but I don't
think they ever should have been put in
that situation in the first place yeah
so this is the meat of the conversation
in my opinion which is let's first talk
about ROI or rules of engagement you
know one of the things I think I even
tweeted it at one point was saying look
some of the actions that we're seeing
from the police would have been illegal
or heavily frowned upon when I was in
Iraq right the rules of engagement and
one of the situations that I always
caveat say look there's incredible
complexity and in today's environment
being a police officer is almost an
impossible task right because literally
everyone's filming you all the time
everyone's agitating like there's just
so many issues that go on but I think it
was in Louisville the cops were shot at
so you can imagine you're police officer
somebody shoots at you and the way that
I've heard the story and kind of what
I've read is they basically turned and
they shot back it just happened to be
with a group of protesters there
somebody gets shot and killed now was
that the guy who shot them was it
somebody else that there's a bunch of
kind of unknowns and so it's less about
that specific instance as much as if you
or I were in Iraq or Afghanistan
and we turned a shot yeah well if we
turned and shot into a group of unarmed
people and ended up killing somebody
there's a lot of questions going on and
you know in today's day and age there's
actually probably a lot of pressure
because there's just a different rules
of engagement right yeah I mean there's
a whole host of different incidents we
could go over and bring up we're you
know we've seen on video police you know
shooting people in the back as they're
trying to run away and it's like oh my
god if I did that in Iraq I'd be
court-martialed you're not allowed to do
that this is crazy
and I'm not a law enforcement expert but
I think we have created quite a quagmire
in this country we have these
long-standing issues regarding police
brutality but it's not just about
policing it's about the entire legal
structure and how it functions in the
court system things that you know should
have been fixed a long time ago and you
know these institutions whether it's the
police or the military I think there's a
tendency to try to hold everything
together with duct tape and you know 550
cord rather than you know bring forth
real policy measures real legislation
and really you know fix the problem